.
- Sur la route vers Camp-Perrin,
une partie de la montagne
s'est littéralement déversée
sur le chemin principal.
Des maisons effondrées
longent la route, témoignant
de la violence du tremblement
de terre il y a quatre jours
à peine.
Cette grand-mère nous raconte
que ces trois petits-enfants se
trouvaient dans cette pièce lors
du séisme. Ils se font soigner
à Port-au-Prince et aux Cayes.
C'est elle qui les élève.
(en créole)
"Mon petit-fils a le bras
éventré, a besoin d'une greffe,
dit-elle. Aidez-nous."
(en créole)
Donc, c'est ici?
Gerda Lovermon était dans
sa maison avec ses sept enfants
lors de l'événement,
comme elle dit.
(en créole)
Pas de victimes?
Le toit en tôle semble
avoir sauvé sa famille,
car ces maisons semblent
avoir mieux résisté
que celles en béton.
JEAN MAXIME EUGÈNE, économe
Séminaire Collège Mazenod
- Comme on dit, c'est pas
les tremblements de terre
qui tuent; c'est le béton
qui tue, parce que...
Il y a des petites maisons,
là, je vois qu'il y a
des petites maisons
sur les routes qui ont...
résisté au tremblement de terre.
Mais les grandes maisons...
- Ici, à Mazenod, le lieu
spirituel où les prêtres
haïtiens font leur retraite,
deux personnes sont mortes
sous les décombres.
- Toutes nos structures
sont démolies. Le collège,
le petit similaire, notre
noviciat, nos maisons.
Toutes nos structures,
sauf ces deux maisons-là,
qui sont restés...
- Comment se fait-il?
Est-ce qu'elles ont été
construites plus tard?
- Oui, elles ont été
construites plus tard.
- Mais un prêtre
a pu être sauvé.
- Bon, après le temps...
la maison s'est écoulée.
On avait un prêtre ici, là.
- Ah! oui?
Dans le trou, là?
- Dans le trou.
On a creusé le trou...
pour le retirer.
Le trou n'était pas là.
- Et il est sorti vivant?
- Il est sorti vivant.
- "Personne du gouvernement
ou des autorités haïtiennes
ne sont venues; nous sommes
abandonnés à notre sort",
nous dit-on.
(chant)
Malgré la dévastation,
Gerda et ses enfants
remercient le bon Dieu
d'être encore en vie.
(chant)
Elle attend son huitième enfant
avec impatience, car malgré
tout, la vie doit continuer.
Ici Azeb Wolde-Giorghis,
Radio-Canada,
Camp-Perrin, Ha